in a previous video we began to think
about potential energy as a function of
inter nuclear distance for diatomic
molecules what do I mean by diatomic
molecules well we looked at molecular
hydrogen which is just or h2 which is
just two hydrogen's covalently bonded to
each other and at standard temperature
and pressure there they would naturally
the distance between the two nuclei
would go would be based on where there
is the lowest potential energy and if
you were to squeeze them together you
would have to put energy into the system
and have a higher potential energy or if
you were to pull them apart you would
have to put energy into the system and
have a higher potential energy what I
want to do in this video is do a little
bit of a worked example over here I have
three potential energies as a function
of inter nuclear distance graphs and
what I'm going to tell you is one of
these is molecular hydrogen one of these
is molecular nitrogen or diatomic
nitrogen and two and one of these is
diatomic oxygen and what I want you to
think about pause this video is which
graph is the potential energy as a
function of inter nuclear distance for
each of these diatomic molecules and
I'll give you a hint look at the low
point in potential energy the low point
in potential energy is what you would
typically observe that diatomic
molecules in turn nuclear distance to be
at standard temperature and pressure and
this distance right over here is going
to be a function of two things it's
going to be a function of how small the
atoms actually are how small their radii
are so smaller atoms are in gentlemen
have a shorter stable internuclear
distance but the other thing to think
about is the bond order between these
atoms and I'll give you a little bit of
a hint diatomic hydrogen you just have a
single covalent bond for diatomic
nitrogen it is a triple bond and for
diatomic oxygen it is a double bond so
the higher order of the bond that will
also bring the two atoms closer together
and it also makes it have a higher
energy the energy required to separate
the atoms remember we talked about it in
the previous video this right over here
is the bond energy and so with that said
pause the video and try to figure it out
which of these is the graphs of h2 which
is ends do and which is o2 so let's
first just think about it in terms of
bond energy if you look at it the single
bond double bond triple bond here you
would expect the highest order bond here
to have the highest bond energy and the
highest bond energy is this
salmon-colored one right over here so
just based on that I would say that this
is a good candidate for n2 so this one
right over here this looks like diatomic
nitrogen to me then the next highest
bond energy if you look at it carefully
it looks like this purple one right over
here and so just based on bond order I
would say this is a good candidate for
Oh two and then the lowest bond energy
is this one all right over here and so
just based on the bond order here it's
just a single covalent bond this looks
like a good candidate for diatomic
hydrogen let's also think about the
radii of these atoms if we get a
periodic table of elements here we can
see that hydrogen only has one electron
in that first shell and so it's going to
be the smallest so that makes sense over
here that your distance where you have
the lowest potential energy is shortest
for the diatomic molecule that's made up
of the smallest atoms but then when you
look at the other two something
interesting happens
remember your radius for an atom
increases as you go down a column but as
you go to the right on a row your radius
decreases because you're adding more and
more electrons to the same shell but the
Coulomb forces are increasing between
that outermost shell and your nucleus
and so if you just look at that trend as
you go from nitrogen to oxygen you would
actually expect your atomic
radius to get a little bit smaller
they're right next to each other they
might be close but you say okay oxygen
you have one extra electron in that same
second shell maybe it's going to be a
little bit smaller so if you were to
base things just on that you'd say all
right well the inter nuclear distance
for this salmon-colored one is a little
bit shorter maybe that one is oxygen and
maybe this one is nitrogen but they
would be close and I would say in
general the bond order would trump
things and the bond order because you
see this high bond energy that's the
biggest giveaway that this is going to
be the higher bond order diatomic
molecule or n2 they're close an atomic
radius but this is what makes all of the
difference and we'll take those two
nitrogen atoms and squeeze them together
just a little bit more even though they
might be a little bit bigger and so I
feel pretty good with this labeling